I'm like okay cool I've got my general
ID here to find an area between two
curves I'm gonna work out the area of
the top one and then subtract the area
of the bottom one that's the overall
path through this question now I need to
knuckle down and get the details I need
to know where a and B are for instance
where are those stat points and
endpoints and then I'm going to
substitute in G of X take away f of X
okay so let's go ahead and work out what
the intersection points are so to find
intersection points always important to
tell us what you're doing and why you're
doing it like yesterday we saw we are
going to solve simultaneously in order
to work out where do these two parabolas
collide so that's going to be f of X
equals G of X this is the thing that we
want to solve okay so let's go ahead and
substitute in I've got x squared minus
4x plus 5 and then I've got minus x
squared plus 6x plus 17 okay so our in
order to solve this I'm gonna get
everything on the left hand side so let
me give you a second to do that unless
you already have go ahead and post in
the comments what expression you get on
the left hand side if you get everything
away from the right hand side and add
and subtract terms to make it all
equivalent what are you going to get on
the left any takers
very nice okay well done parent okay so
what's the way we're going to do this
well I'm going to add to both sides I'm
going to add an x squared I'm going to
subtract a 6x and I'm going to subtract
a 17 because if I do that to both sides
you can see that's just going to clean
out the right-hand side right so what
does that leave me with I've got two
lots of x squared on the left-hand side
minus 4x minus 6x does give me minus 10x
and then five take away 17 that'll give
me minus 12 and then that clean 0 on the
right-hand side so you can see here I
can do better than this right everything
is even
how convenient so I'm going to divide
through by 2 and that will give me a
much neater quadratic to work with so x
squared minus 5x minus 6 is what I'm
getting if I divide through by 2 and so
now I'm searching for a factorization go
ahead and post in the chat if you can
get me the two factors for those what
are the two numbers were going to be
using be really careful with your plus
or minus signs okay yeah nicely done
fantastic okay so Alexis is in first
thumbs up for getting there so X take
away 6x plus one do those numbers add to
negative 5 yes they do do they multiply
to negative 6 yes they do so fantastic
things are looking good now what was the
point of doing that why did I factorize
the point was looking back at my own
working I was trying to find
intersection points that's what I was
after
right so therefore I'm gonna solve this
and I'm just gonna say X is equal to
negative 1 or 6 now when we were having
a look at some of the areas yesterday
you notice that we got more than one
solution and we had to look at our
solutions and say which is the one
that's important okay because sometimes
one is irrelevant like something you
notice though it's like oh we're in the
first quadrant I don't need these
negative answers right but in this case
negative 1 & 6 they both matter because
they are both the values that I'm
looking for and in fact you can see this
on the graph here let me do it to a
different color this over here does sure
enough
look like negative one and this over
here does sure enough look like six so
this is a good indicator that we've
found the correct values so using our
sketch we've put the relevant
information on now I've worked out a and
B and now I'm going to do G of X take
away f of X so let's have a go at this
continuing my working my total area is
going to be equal to let me slide it in
right underneath because um I have that
big honking diagram on the right-hand
side
I'm now integrating from negative one to
six the first one will be G of X and
then I'll subtract f of X so what was G
of X it was minus x squared plus 6x plus
17 that's with respect to X and then mm
am I gonna fit it there I'll fit it just
above that set of axes there I'm gonna
subtract the integral same boundaries of
f of X well that's gonna be what we say
x squared I think was minus 4x plus 5
from memory let's just scroll up and see
if I got that right hey hooray I have a
decent memory okay so I've got my G of X
and my f of X and you can see I'm
subtracting in this particular order
because I know ones on top and ones on
the bottom now at this point I'm again
gonna refer to one of the things that
mrs. Lee's taught us about the
properties of a definite integral I want
you to notice that we've got the same
boundaries for the first integral from
negative 1 to 6 as we do for the second
integral right they're both from
negative 1 to 6 so there's a consequence
we can actually combine these two
integrals into one and this is going to
be sort of a common theme all the way
through this like integrals are work we
hear a lot of work to go ahead think
about the calculus do you know increase
indices divide then all the substitution
like every single term that's there
you're gonna have to substitute two
things the upper lower bound and the
lower bound so anywhere we can combine
different integrals into one we will so
I'm gonna do that because the boundaries
are identical I can say I think I'm
gonna need a little more space down here
I can say this integral is from negative
1 to 6 because they both match and then
cuz I'm subtracting these two one from
the other I'm just going to go through
term by term and collect like terms just
be careful when you do your subtraction
it's going to be minus x squared minus x
squared let me just say that one more
time slowly this minus x squared here
I'm going to subtract x squared so that
of course leaves me with minus 2x
squared then you've got a 6x I'm gonna
subtract negative 4x so it's going to be
plus 10x and then lastly I've got this
17 and I'm gonna subtract 5 so that
gives me plus 12
with respect to X now hopefully what
we've just put into that our integrand
there the thing being integrated
hopefully that looks familiar because we
just worked with terms like that
up above just here I've can fit on the
same screen actually just here when we
were solving these two simultaneously
that's because the way we did it was we
got everything together on one side
which is effectively what we did here in
the integral ok now I can do one step
better than this I'm just like before
when I was finding the points of
intersection and I took out a factor of
two I'm gonna do that again so factor
two at the front negative 1 to 6 and
then everything else comes for the ride
I'm dividing everything by 2 there I am
so I'm looking for at this point before
I go any further can I just get some
thumbs up if you're okay with that the
things I'm checking are were you okay
with the graph and how I did that and
were you okay with this integral I
haven't integrated yet obviously but
looking to make sure yep fantastic
excellent thank you so much everyone
good to see all right so I came ready to
integrate now ok so I've got this two at
the front it's just a constant
coefficient and now I'm gonna actually
do the integration here so it's negative
X cubed on 3 plus 5x squared on 2 plus
6x and my boundaries are from negative 1
to 6 ok so I'm ready to go ahead and do
this I've got to do it term by term and
I've got to make sure I'm careful with
all of my signs and all the rest so I'm
going to draw some big bracket
here and then then just go through one
at a time so I'm getting - 216 on free
if you didn't know that six cubed was
216 no problems your calculator will
help you there but you're gonna
encounter you're gonna be doing lots of
cubing and hype house so you'll
encounter this number it's not that I'm
super smart I've just done this
calculation a lot I've got five lots of
x squared which is six squared so five
watts or 36 divided by two and then I've
got 36 hanging out on the end on what
time there's my upper bound and then I'm
going to subtract my lower bound so
let's put in negative one now I've got
negative watch out there's a minus X
cubed there right so now I've got
negative one cubed which is negative one
that's divided by three plus five lots
off negative one squared I'm gonna put
that five back up the top which is one
it's all divided by two and there's six
lots of negative one and I'm going to
end my curly brace so at this point
you're probably going to reach for your
calculator in fact I'm I'm gonna reach
for my calculator and let's see what you
get see if you crunch your numbers and
get exactly the same thing that I do
let's go ahead and evaluate this be
careful with your input and your
fractions as well spare a thought for
those of us who are so old that when we
were putting things like this into our
calculators our fractions didn't look
like fractions you just have one line
across the top and you're kind of like
I've got fractures on fractions this
looks ridiculous so at least your
fractions will tell you when they are
what they say they are and make sure
you've got all your minus signs there
one over three plus five over two minus
six and make sure you close all your
brackets okay now before I post my
answer I'm actually going to wait and
see if people are gonna be willing to
share with me in the chat what they've
got I've got a number right here and
I'll prove it by holding it up to the
camera in a second but I wonder how many
of you have got an answer and if you can
share with us
Perrins got an answer that's fantastic
let's see if anyone else has the same
one
yes upcoming coming up something that's
that sounds weird given the thumbs up to
someone's already given an on top is is
the cheap way but that's fine
Thank You Abby for going ahead and
actually typing those symbols I
appreciate the effort well done
okay so I'm encouraged because let's say
I don't know if my um webcams gonna
manage that but there you go
I think that's slightly visible is what
do you think mrs. Lee's give me a thumbs
up or thumbs down you read that too
blurry I don't know that's fine that way
light it's it's it's 343 on three like
you guys got so fantastic well done let
me write that in 343 on three now
there's only a single region here so
we've actually done everything we can
say well I should say there's only a
single region because we've already done
the top takeaway bottom it's all been
sort of baked into our working so I'm
going to conclude there the area is 343
on three square units tada
done so that was like in terms of the
integration that was no harder than what
you've done before but you do have to be
careful with all of your terms and where
possible you were reducing you know
multiple incra rules into one and then
you get this value okay now I said I was
only gonna do one example and i'm i
partly lied because i'm gonna give you a
half of an extra example that's based on
this one okay we're not gonna do the
full working but is a really important
caution to take when you're dealing with
areas that are between curves okay so